we were continuing to follow up on this
story from the shooting at the
Pittsburgh Tree of Life synagogue I told
you earlier in the show that this
shooting left more left 11 dead more
than 10 11 dead I can be more precise
and a certain number injured that
appears to be right around 6:00 at this
time and the setup for our sort of
understanding of what's going on here
does involve Donald Trump and you have
to understand that Donald Trump has
emboldened white supremacy after
charlottesville Donald Trump said that
there were very fine people on both
sides including the side of the
neo-nazis and all of the other stories
that we've discussed which I won't bore
you with now but you can certainly find
in our archives this has now led to a
group of progressive Jewish leaders who
have told Donald Trump that he's simply
not welcome in Pittsburgh the site of
this horrible horrible shooting that
took place over the weekend until he
actually denounces white nationalism
after the synagogue shooting now Trump
spoke earlier today and talked about the
evils of anti-semitism but there has
been a big-picture lack of very sort of
specific and precise condemnation of
movements that we know have been
emboldened and catalyzed and coalesced
by the Trump presidency and so 11
members of the Pittsburgh affiliate of
bend the arc a Jewish partnership for
justice wrote a letter which says quote
our Jewish community is not the only
group you have targeted you have also
deliberately undermined the safety of
people of color
Muslims LGBTQ people and people with
disabilities yesterday's massacre is not
the first act of terror you incited
against a minority group in our country
recall that Donald Trump spoke at the
Holocaust Museum in Israel and didn't
even mention Jews recall that Donald
Trump wrote in their guestbook how it
was great to be there with all of his
friends sort of like it's an amusement
park of some kind so I support these
Jewish leaders some are already being
criticized for quote
playing politics after a tragedy and we
hear this after many mass shootings and
many instances of violence committed
with firearms politics is what gets us
into these messes in many cases and it
is not an argument to say you shouldn't
politicize X Y or Z are we politicizing
it in a way that is appropriate given
the political circumstances that connect
to the act that took place that is
really the question and that's sort of
like you know I I tend to get away from
phrases like that's offensive when we're
actually trying to argue the argue the
merits of policy or of an idea let's
focus on why it's discriminatory or why
it's unjust or why it will not have the
intended effect that we are looking for
but in the same way that you have a
movement which seeks to say I'm offended
isn't an argument that same movement
should be saying politicizing a tragedy
isn't a criticism if politics are
related to why the tragedy took place
they are saying we aren't going to have
the person who we believe is espousing
rhetoric that fuels this type of hatred
come here immediately after spreading
false flag anti media anti-democratic
propaganda mixed in with two or three
words about the horrible incident that
took place and in fact just hours after
the synagogue shooting took place Trump
and right before by the way going back
to tweeting about the World Series as
Donald Trump was doing yesterday Trump
went right back to attacking the media
saying quote there is great anger in our
country
caused in part by inaccurate and even
fraudulent reporting of the news the
fake news media the true enemy of the
people must stop the open and obvious
hostility to report the news accurately
and fairly that will do much to put out
the flame of anger and outrage and we
will then be able to bring all sides
together in peace and harmony fake news
must end what about white nationalism
must end what about white supremacy must
end what a
out the anti-semitism that we are seeing
is in great part fomented by the
rhetoric of his administration and this
is why we're having the problem in the
first place
it is despicable and I 100% support the
Jewish leaders of Pittsburgh and in
practical terms Trump as a source of
comfort after a tragedy is pretty
laughable anyway as we saw after the
killing of American servicemembers in
nee Jer and Donald Trump's completely
abortive gongshow phone calls to their
widows and many of the other stories it
is an absolute and total joke that
Trump's presence would in any way
provide any kind of comfort in a bad
time so he should stay away and I agree
with the sentiment of the Jewish leaders
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania I am really
thrilled to tell you that one of today's
sponsors is a service that I personally
use myself called simple habit and you
can get a free trial at simple habit
comm slash Pakman it is really important
to take a break from Twitter to take a
break from the inundation of politics
and media and Trump and all of the stuff
that's going on and a really great way
to take that break and sort of do a
mental reset is with simple habit a
guided meditation app that just won the
2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app perfect for people with
busy lifestyles you just need five
minutes a day
they have morning meditations
meditations for going to sleep
meditations for dealing with headaches
stress meditations for athletes for
fighting procrastination for promoting
creativity they have a huge catalogue of
hundreds and hundreds of meditations for
almost anything you're trying to
accomplish and you can use the app to
track all of your progress they also
have music you can listen to that's
designed specifically to keep you calm
and focused while you're working or
reading go check it out you can try it
free for seven days at simple habit calm
slash Pakman I've put a link underneath
this video